happy anniversary Hulu
pinky are you pondering what I'm
pondering I think so brain isn't it
Cooler's 15th anniversary but once
you're right pinky happy
birthday this is so exciting happy
anniversary happy anniversary Hulu happy
anniversary Hulu happy anniversary Hulu
we love you happy Hulu happy 15th
anniversary happy birthday Hulu happy
15th Birthday 15 amazing years congrats
congrats congrats congrats on 15 years
Hulu it's exciting happy anniversary I
hope your parents throw you an amazing
party we feel very old hard work
dedication longevity let's go
congratulations cheers to you in 15
years happy 15th anniversary go you
happy 15th
[Music]
15 years Hulu 15 good years yes you know
Green is my favorite color and also on
you I could spend hours just watching
you happy 15th anniversary Hulu happy
15th anniversary Hulu I knew we were
meant to be congrats happy anniversary
happy 15th happy 15th happy 50s happy
birthday happy 15th anniversary it's
been 15 amazing years who hears them
anymore congrats congrats you better be
in by curfew happy 15 years Hulu happy
anniversary
[Music]
[Applause]
wow 15 years you you have a driving
permit happy anniversary Hulu happy
anniversary happy anniversary happy
anniversary Hulu you're 15 and you're
gorgeous keep at it let's pop some
champagne
also uh while I have you can I get a
free subscription
[Music]
foreign